[Music]
[Michael Feolo]
dbGap is a database of phenotypes and genotypes.
This repository houses the data produced in large
scale, usually genomic-based, research studies.
dbGap has an advanced search
interface. It's solar-faceted.
It allows you to actually
delve into the study details,
the variable details, and even see the
distributions and the values within the variables.
That can all be made public before
you request access.
This way, you can browse the data and make
sure that you want to request access.
Some of the variables that we allow
you to search for are individual-level
phenotypic data and potentially
different types of molecular data.
We designed a very simple but highly effective
submission scheme where the data sets could be
defined by the submitter, with the data dictionary
that describes each element within that data set.
We want to try to annotate those variables, that
were collected differently by different studies,
to some control vocabularies.
And these are largely found in the UMLS which is a
NLM product. It's a metathesaurus
of several different vocabularies.
And so we've been working with a number of groups.
One of the groups is actually from Lister
Hill. They've been mapping the variables,
when appropriate, to LOINC terms.
And so, we can take in those annotations and
we can make that part of our search interface.
We've worked with a number
of other groups to do this.
There's an NHGRI-funded, it's called Phoenix.
It's a controlled set of measures,
but those can also be tied back to variables
in a similar way to the UMLS vocabularies.
Another group, based in Heidelberg
Germany, called the Medical DataModels
are mapping to UMLS CUI terms
and the NHLBI-funded TOPMed project.
With the third party annotations, we're able
to allow people to search across studies and
find variables within these studies that
were previously more difficult to find.
We're incorporating these third-party annotations
to include this within our FHIR schema.
So, the FHIR schema is an API to query the
phenotypic and study metadata from the study.
And embedded within the FHIR data structure,
you can put the controlled terms as a system.
I want to get the word out
there that it's a free resource.
Use dbGap to augment your research.
[Music]
[Music fades to silence]